WELCOME BACK.
WE DO HAVE NEW DEVELOPMENT THIS
MORNING IN THAT POLICE RAID IN
KANSAS.
THE KANSAS BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATIONS IS NOW LEADING
THAT PROBE INTO LAST FRIDAY'S
RATE OF THE MARION COUNTY
RECORD.
POLICE SEARCHED BOTH THE HOME
AND THE OFFICE OF THE
NEWSPAPERS OWNERS, AND THEY
SEIZED COMPUTERS AND PHONES OF
REPORTERS AND EDITORS.
THEY CLAIMED IT STEMMED FROM AN
INVESTIGATION INTO IDENTITY
THEFT.
A COFFEE SHOP OWNER HAD ACCUSED
--
ABOUT DUIS SHE RECEIVED ABOUT
15 YEARS AGO.
THE PAPER SAYS THEY GOT THOSE
FROM A SOURCE, THEY WITHIN
TRYING TO VERIFY THE
INFORMATION, AND THAT THEY ONLY
PUBLISHED IT AFTER SHE STARTED
ACCUSING THEM PUBLICLY.
WE SHOULD NOTE THE COFFEE SHOP
OWNER PREVIOUSLY BARRED THE
PAPER FROM COVERING THE PUBLIC
EVENT OF A REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, MARION COUNTY RECORD
PUBLISHER AND EDITOR ERIC MEYER
SAYS THAT HIS 98-YEAR-OLD
MOTHER JOANNE, WHO WAS A
CO-OWNER OF THE PAPER,
COLLAPSED AND DIED ON SATURDAY,
THE DAY AFTER POLICE RAIDED HER
HOME.
ACCORDING TO THE PAPER, MAYER
HAD BEEN STRESSED BEYOND HER
LIMITS AND OVERWHELMED BY HOURS
OF SHOCK AND GRIEF AFTER THE
ILLEGAL POLICE RAIDS.
ERIC JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, ERIC.
WE ARE ALL DEEPLY SORRY FOR THE
LOSS OF YOUR MOTHER.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> OF COURSE.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE POLICE
ABOUT ALL OF THIS, BECAUSE THEY
DID THIS AND THEY WERE HANDLING
THE INVESTIGATION PRIOR.
WE DIDN'T HEAR BACK, BUT I WANT
TO READ PEOPLE A STATEMENT FROM
THE POLICE CHIEF ON SUNDAY.
HE SAID I BELIEVE WHEN THE REST
OF THE STORY IS AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC, THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
THAT IS BEING QUESTIONED WILL
BE VINDICATED.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY MORE
ANSWERS FROM POLICE ABOUT WHY
THEY DID THIS?
>> WE FINALLY WERE ABLE TO
OBTAIN THE PROBABLE CAUSE
AFFIDAVIT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
SUPPORT THE SEARCH WARRANT.
IT WAS FILED THREE DAYS AFTER
THE SEARCHES WERE CONDUCTED,
IT'S A LITTLE SUSPICIOUS.
BUT IT INTERESTINGLY REFUTES
MOST OF THE THINGS PLAYED
AGAINST US, AND THE ALLEGATIONS
WERE THAT WE OBTAINED THIS
DOCUMENT AND GAVE IT TO THE
VICE MAYOR, AND IN THE DOCUMENT
ITSELF SHE SAYS SHE GOT IT FROM
THE SAME SOURCE WE GOT IT.
FROM WHICH SUPPORTS OUR
CONTENTION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT WE TOLD HIM
ABOUT THIS.
THIS WAS OUR DISCLOSURE TO THEM
THAT THERE WAS A DOCUMENT OUT
THERE THAT MAYBE SOMEONE HAD
DONE, THERE WAS AN ALLEGATION
THAT POLICE WERE IGNORING THE
FACT THAT THE RESTAURANT OWNER
HAD BEEN DRIVING FOR YEARS
WITHOUT A DRIVERS LICENSE, SO
WE ORDERED THE POLICE TO --
THEY NEVER ASKED A SINGLE
QUESTION.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND, SEARCH
WARRANTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
SORT OF A LAST RESORT, IF YOU
CAN'T GET THE INFORMATION IN
THE OTHER WAY, THEY COULD ASK.
HERE'S THE DOCUMENT WE
OBTAINED.
IT WAS SITTING ON MY DESK, NEXT
TO THE COMPUTER.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE IT.
>> WELL, THE FACT THAT --
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
I'M LEARNING AND WE'RE LEARNING
THROUGH OUR REPORTING THAT THE
PROBABLE CAUSE I COULD DAVE IT
WAS SUBMITTED AFTER THIS
MAGISTRATE JUDGE GRANTED A
SEARCH WARRANT.
I THINK THAT RAISES IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS.
I DO WANT TO NOTE, YOU HAVE
SAID THAT THE PAPER WAS
INVESTIGATING AT ONE POINT THE
POLICE CHIEF GETTY AND CODY,
BUT NEVER PUBLISHED THAT
INVESTIGATION, WERE ABLE TO
VERIFY SOME OF THE CLAIMS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT PERSON
FACTORED INTO THIS RAID?
>> I JUST --
SPECULATION.
ODDITIES ABOUT THIS, THERE ARE
ALSO LONG-STANDING ANIMOSITIES
IN THIS TOWN FROM VARIOUS
DIFFERENT FACTIONS.
WHEN I TALKED TO THE RESTAURANT
OWNER AFTER SHE ACCUSED US OF
STEALING THE DOCUMENTS, I WAS
NOT TRYING TO GET YOU ON THIS,
I WAS TRYING TO GET THE VICE
MAYOR.
HIS HOUSE WAS ALSO RATED, HER
COMPUTER AND HER PHONE WERE
ALSO --
>> THIS IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU, YOUR
COMMUNITY, AND YOUR PAPER.
, BUT THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
AMERICA BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FREEDOM OF
THE PRESS.
YOUR LAWYER WROTE A LETTER TO
THE POLICE CHIEF AND SAYING
THAT YOU'RE TREATING YOUR PAPER
LIKE A DRUG CARTEL OR A STREET
GANG, AND YOUR FILING A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT, IS THAT RIGHT?
AND IF SO, ON WHAT GROUNDS?
>> WE ARE PLANNING TO DO A
VIOLATION
BUT, THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED
YET.
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT NOW THAT THE
KBI IS TAKING OVER, THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME COOLER HEADS THAT
PREVAIL, SHALL WE SAY.
AND THEY'RE APPARENTLY GOING TO
EXAMINE NOT ONLY WHAT THE
EVIDENCE SAYS, BUT WHETHER IT
WAS PROPER TO GO AFTER IT THE
WAY THAT THEY WERE GOING AFTER
IT.
>> DOZENS OF NEWS ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING CNN, HAVE CONDEMNED
WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE.
THE FREEDOM OF THE PRESS
FOUNDATION CALLED THIS A LATEST
EXAMPLE OF AMERICAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CHEATING
--
IN A MANNER PREVIOUSLY
ASSOCIATED WITH AUTHORITARIAN
REGIMES.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT BIGGER
PICTURE HERE AS A JOURNALIST --
YOU'VE BEEN THERE ALL NIGHT
TRYING TO GET THE PAPER OUT
THIS MORNING DESPITE ALL OF
THIS.
JUST WHAT THIS INDICATES TO YOU?
>> WELL, I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
THIS BEFORE.
THERE IS ONE CASE YEARS AND
YEARS AGO INVOLVING A STUDENT
NEWSPAPER, BUT WHERE YOU HEAR
OF THIS IS IN THE THIRD WORLD.
I HAD A GRAD STUDENT, I WAS A
FACULTY MEMBER OF THE
UNIVERSITY FOR MANY YEARS.
AND I HAD A GRAD STUDENT FROM
EGYPT WHO TALKED ABOUT THINGS
LIKE THIS REGULARLY HAPPENING
IN THE AUTHORITARIAN REGIME IN
EGYPT.
AND WE DID A PAPER ON HOW THIS
DAMAGED JOURNALISTS AND
PREVENTED JOURNALIST FROM
GETTING INFORMATION ABLE TO SEE
IT CLEARLY AND CONCISELY SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
THIS WILL DRY UP SOURCES.
WE HAD PEOPLE --
SINCE WE'VE LOST FOUR COMPUTERS,
I CAN'T GET ON FACEBOOK BECAUSE
I'VE GOT A THING THAT'S TIED
INTO MYSELF PHONE.
SOMEBODY CALLED UP AND SAID,
HEY, THERE'S THIS REALLY
INTERESTING THING YOU HAVE TO
READ ON FACEBOOK.
AND I SAID I CAN'T LOOK AT IT,
CAN YOU SEND IT TO ME?
I SAID NO, I CAN'T SEND IT TO
YOU.
THEY MIGHT COME AND SEIZE MY
COMPUTER.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE ORIGINAL LEAD IN THIS, THE
ORIGINAL LEAD TO THE DOCUMENT
WAS PROBABLY A GIMMICK AND A
DIVORCE CASE.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY THE REASON
WHY WE DIDN'T RUN IT.
>> WELL ERIC, --
>> WE HAD INVESTIGATED THE
CHIEF, AND WE COULDN'T GET
ANYWHERE WITH IT.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE NOW HEARING
ADDITIONAL THINGS ABOUT THAT.
SO WE MAY TURN UP AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY, ALL HER NOTES
ARE IN POSSESSION OF THE CHIEF
RIGHT NOW.
THEY SEIZED A COMPUTER OR A
REPORTER THAT WAS WORKING ON
THAT.
>> HE WAS GONE IN THE WEEK THAT
ALL THIS HAPPENED, SHE WAS SICK
THIS WEEK.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHY THAT
COMPUTER --
>> ERIC, YOU'RE WELCOME BACK AS
YOU LEARN MORE.
WE HAVE INVITED AND TO KEEP THE
INVITATION OPEN FOR THE POLICE
CHIEF, THE SHERIFF, ANYONE FROM
THAT POLICE DEPARTMENT TO JOIN
US FROM THE PROGRAM.
--
>> IT WAS A MAJOR ORDEAL BUT WE
MADE IT.
WE WERE GOING TO DO IT AND WE
HAD THE HANDWRITING ON PIECES